hi there steve here
today i'm going to do a video out of
schedule uh i'm trying to be more uh
regular in my videos so that we can
repair transcripts and those will
continue to be there every thursday
but sometimes i have something on my
mind that i just want to talk about and
today is such a day
a friend of mine sent me a link to an
article from a czech website
saying that bill gates apparently wants
to learn french and he the one thing he
wants to do in his life is to speak
foreign languages and he feels unhappy
that he can't do so
so then i uh googled and i found the
original
interview in english i'll put both links
in the description here
the important thing is that bill gates
with all the money that he has the one
thing he wants to do is to speak foreign
languages so for those of us who study
foreign languages
and of course sometimes we see these
extremely wealthy people who have yachts
and expensive cars and five homes and
and can go to expensive restaurants and
stuff and it's important to remember
that we are happy
inside ourselves
uh and all these other things that we
can buy
with money cars and yachts and expensive
meals um those are only props those are
tools that we hope are going to make us
happy but we're only happy inside really
we aren't happy
just having a car doesn't necessarily
make us happy we might be happy when we
sit in the car but we don't live in the
car so if we look at the opportunity to
become happy through learning a language
the amount of time that we actually
enjoy the language while studying while
reading while visiting the country while
speaking with people uh you know i
suggest
that that gives us more happiness than
owning a lamborghini
or a yacht
so
for those of you out there who are keen
language learners you have a chance to
do something that bill gates wants to do
but so far hasn't been able to do
apparently he studied
some latin and greek school and he was
doing duolingo and didn't continue for
whatever reason
of course i would like to suggest that
bill gates
study at linc
i think it's ideal for someone like him
i think he's a an intellectual he's a
reader he wants to not just learn french
so he can like mark zuckerberg go and
and answer a few questions in beijing or
in paris
but i would imagine that he would like
to discover french civilization french
culture
achieve a level of vocabulary so that he
can go to paris and have intelligent
adult conversations with french people
in which case i
humbly submit that the best place for
him to learn french is that link pardon
the plug at any rate even without that
those of you who study languages and and
all of us who study succeed to some
extent
we are achieving something that
at least two very wealthy people in the
world mark zuckerberg and bill gates
want to achieve
so there you have it i just wanted to
throw that one in um
well maybe we'll get a a
transcript up next week but i'm going to
put this one up today because it's
topical right now thank you
thanks for listening